october
i'm gonna head your way
and see you today
though sometimes i wonder why i should
sometimes you don't seem to care
and that makes me mad brother
and then when i see you it doesn't
really make me feel any better
should it
is that what this is for
it doesn't seem to be
it actually just makes me remember the
way things used to be
better times
it makes me wonder why things turned out
this way
what did i do wrong
should i have done something different
what could i have said
you never let me down ever
but now you won't even talk to me
i was looking at some of the things you
wrote to me in the past
i opened up an email
in it you wrote i feel it again
washing over me
the descent into degeneration and
disintegration
the smell of filth black water mixed
with blood and gun powder and [__]
the american soldier covered in filth
11 months into a 16-month deployment
the insurgents grown
men hiding behind children
women wailing over the dead explosions
and screams and fragments of concrete
flying through the air
and frogmen enter the scene to take the
hand of the american soldier
and pull him from the whirlpool
to set his feet back on the rock and
speak words of hope
we are the prophets of doom and
destruction we enter an area
and take back the lost pride of america
we redden the stripes blew the field
and make the stars of our tattered and
humiliated battle ensign
shine once again
we hold it high we carry a nation on our
shoulders
and we bring the enemy to its knees
we do not live in fear of death or
wounding
or even worse rejection by the country
we love
i feel my mind coming apart and the old
sleeping animal coming out
i tried to keep it inside but it cannot
help
but attend the call to battle
when you originally wrote that to me
i thought to myself
yep he's there again
where he should be
i knew it wouldn't last forever
but where are you now
now you seem distant
in my head i can see you smile i can
hear you laugh
but it's only in my head
i was surfing the other day it was one
of those days
a good day solid swell
no wind tide was low and the sky was
clear and bright
i kept looking out toward the outside
where you used to sit and wait for the
big set waves
i thought i saw you a couple times
but it wasn't you
i heard someone paddling behind me
must be you i thought
no nothing
no one's there
i'm all alone out here
everything is the same but nothing is
the same
everything has changed but nothing has
changed
does anything ever change
look at the waves as they approach the
shore
each wave formed through random
combinations of wind and sea and
pressure
and each one completely unique
and when they break they're gone forever
but then another one comes behind it
and another one
they are all different
but they're all the same
and i see some of the past and the
future and i see some of the future in
the past
and i begin to wonder which is which
how did i get here
where am i going to end up
where are you
i look at some more of your writing
you are telling a story writing a story
about a man about god
about life about death
and this is what you wrote
i am ready to go he thought to himself
but for you i wait for the appointed
time
thy will he said to himself
and closed his eyes and placed his hands
on the pages
as if there was some strength there and
he prayed
while he prayed he also thought of past
times
he breathed in deep and exhaled
deliver us from the evil one he muttered
and he thought of all the reasons he had
no right to say this prayer
at that he steadied himself
opened his eyes and looked out into the
first light of the morning
he saw a face not his own looking back
at him from the window
and disappeared
but he was not startled
this kind of thing was normal
i'm ready for you he thought to himself
while he ran that morning he did not
think about anything
his mind retreated deep into itself or
perhaps it shut down altogether and he
wore
no expression he only looked out at the
sea
and watched as the seabirds glided above
the undulating plane of water
moving close above its surface but
managing somehow
not to touch it
at home he heaved weights around on a
small
concrete slab his routine
effortlessly recited and at the same
time
painfully undertaken again
without thought or care
every morning the same
marking off time until an appointed end
his final rendezvous
that's what you wrote
is that what we are doing here marking
off time
until an appointed end
my memory plays tricks on me
how many days do i remember
how many days do i actually remember
and what good is a day that i can't
remember
did it happen
did it exist
i want to remember every day but i can't
i let some of them go
and i hate that
i want to remember and re-remember the
times
we had together
we played songs on the guitar
but i can't hear them anymore
they are gone
i can't recreate them
i'm not good enough
can we play him again
one more song
here is some more of your writing
i am god's messenger
i am a chieftain of michael the angel
he has granted my request to help you
for it is you
who are doing the bidding of the king
we have heard your many prayers
they burn before us day and night yes
heaven is full of the fragrance of your
prayers
and i bring glad tidings from the lord
of lords
he is preparing his mount to ride here
but there is still more to be done on
earth before he wields his scythe and
sword upon it
i bring a message the lord of lords
wants to help you reap the spirits
against whom you are warring
indeed satan has asked to have you
but we will not let that happen
of course you always have a choice
i have come a long way though
i came when we heard your last prayer
you will not be turned
when i read that
it seems obvious
even god was on your side
but if god was on your side how did you
end up like this then
how could you do this to me
what about me
yeah i know i'm being selfish
but what about me
you know what i'm not going to see you
today you can wait
after everything i did for you after
everything we went
through together
you can wait
december
okay
i calm down a little bit
i pride myself in keeping control of my
emotions
but i gotta admit you had me breaking
down a little bit
for a while did you see that
you're probably laughing at me so
i'm gonna come up and see you today
is that cool
i mean it's supposed to be cool
if nothing else just to say goodbye
i'll bring you a beer or two
i don't even drink anymore but you know
what if you crack one open with me
i'll have one with you
like old times
what happened to those times
we were brothers
and when we came home we knew
we made it
we made it man
as crazy it seems i was actually
never that worried about you
maybe you were blessed maybe you were
lucky
maybe it was both but whatever it was it
worked
you even wrote to me during your next
deployment
this is what you wrote
all i interject is my part the firing
and yelling part
but the bullets do not hit me they never
hit me they pass through me like a
miracle
two days ago we drove through a village
and knocked all the power lines down
and it was night and the sparks were
like incoming rpgs
i wished they were and braced
but they weren't and the ieds won't come
either
they won't hit me
it's like i'm being
you capitalized the p in protected
you believed it was a higher power
i can't rightly argue with you on that
but if that's so true
how did this happen
why did this happen where did that
protection go
did it abandon you like you abandoned me
what am i supposed to do now
you know what i'm not going to see you
today
you can wait
february
it's a new year
let's try this again
time heals all wounds they say
so we should be good now right
i should be over it all by now
i'll come see you and at a minimum say
goodbye
just just say goodbye just tell you
that's it no hard feelings don't take it
personally
i've decided i'm gonna go ahead and
proceed
on down the path without you
alone
and i'm used to being alone
no big deal i kind of like it
but even i have to admit it was nice
nice to have someone to talk to nice to
have someone to talk to
without even talking
a look a nod
a smile
no one is smiling back anymore
no one
sometimes i look up at the night sky
that can approximate a smile
i see a smile in the sunset
i don't know why
i try to milk what i can out of every
day i should be
cursing the sunset
that sunset means another day is gone
i should be cursing it but i don't
i take a few minutes when i can and i
watch it
good night al huey
good night chesty
good night stoner
maybe there's some relief that the day
is gone is that it
that that part of the race is over and
there isn't a damn
thing i can do about it
when my oldest daughter was little
we would watch the sunset over the ocean
when we'd get the chance
and she was at that age when she was
only just starting to talk she could
just say a handful of words
when she wanted a drink of milk
she would say nok
when she wanted to go on the swing she
would say ving
when i would throw up her up in the air
and catch her
she would laugh and she would giggle and
she would say the word
again
and she and i were sitting on the sea
wall
it was autumn and the sun was leaning
towards the south
and we watched and she watched
the colors in the sky
red and yellow and orange like
fire and the water ignited
then it turned black and the sun
disappeared
into the ocean and she looked up at me
and she said again
she wanted it back
but i couldn't do anything for her
i was powerless
i still am
i can't stop the clock and i can't bring
back a day
not one single day not one
single minute you get what you get
and that sunset will keep a man's ego in
check
especially when your complete lack of
control
disappoints the little angel sitting on
your knee
and i can't control this situation
either
and that stings
and i don't want to face that
i don't want to say goodbye
that can wait
you can wait
may
springtime
rebirth so i'm told
the winter swell fades but the water
warms up
the days get longer again
i like that
i look at more of your words
they read he found a sleeping spot
happy and excited with anticipation he
thought of the glory which was to come
and he slept tranquilly and did not
dream
the blue midnight sky held no trace of
trouble
almost no clouds only a wisp of silver
gray near the moon
that seemed to be something beautiful
for the humans below
to look at as an omen that something
good might happen
as some kind of sign that heaven awaited
it
the good thing
the good thing you wrote
what am i supposed to do with that
you set me up you know
with thoughts of the good thing
because there we were
you know we were headed in the right
direction
toward the good things
when you listen to me things worked out
always
right you know it
when you listen to me and you put your
damn
heart in check things worked out
what's your problem you listen to your
heart too much you know this
let your emotions get a hold of you you
know it's true
i told you a thousand times ten thousand
times
and you tried to listen and you did
listen sometimes
but your heart couldn't be completely
subdued it was too strong
too strong for its own good
and yeah i know
i know that's what makes you
you fine
but you should have listened to me
you should have listened
and now i am here and you are there
and there is nothing i can do about it
i'm powerless
july
full fledged summer now
campfires and guitar on the regular
where are you at
and let me ask you something if you
aren't going to come around
then can you just let me be
i don't want you in my head right now
i don't want to get dragged back every
time i strum a chord i remember
we were traveling up the coast you and
me
lazy days
surfing by day playing on the git
boxes at night
we were looking for bigger waves
the kind of waves that get the blood
flowing
we found some
but what were we really looking for
you know as well as i
we were looking for that thing
that moment that moment when nothing
else matters that moment that is sourced
directly from the battlefield
hard to find anywhere else so we
we try and get close to it
jiu-jitsu surfing whatever but it's
hard to replace maybe it can't be
replaced
maybe it just is what it is
i think i understood that
i'm not sure you did
i was able to rationalize it figure it
out detach
from it see it from the outside
before that trip up the coast
you had written me these words
send us we are
thirsty for screams and gore and hell
and dirt and [__]
we will hack our way through scores of
bodies
form them up in a pile and burn them so
we can kill by the prior light
somebody spread the good news that the
killer's teeth are
sharp and their guns are clean and their
souls are dead
so no one needs anything but victory and
sacred deference when it is done
you see that was your heart talking
again
the same heart that wrapped around a
girl you met
the same heart that brought my kids
birthday presents
the same heart that was
broken by the loss of our friends
a heart capable of both devotion
and destruction
i told you to let it all go
i told you
but i can't control everything
i'm still powerless
september
a year has passed
or was it yesterday
time seems like a trick but the trick is
on me because it's no trick at all
time does not waver it does not
relinquish
it isn't tricky it just is
and it is moving on without judgment and
without mercy and it will keep
moving
i am coming up to see you today
i have to
i have to say goodbye
i can't do it like this anymore carrying
you around in my head
bringing back the past so often that
it's interfering with the present and
the future
that's not right
that wasn't part of the deal
i arrive
you're still there
where i left you
i brought you a beer and some wax for
your board
and a guitar pick
even though you play better without one
i already went and saw mikey and mark
i save you for last
that's the way it is you were the last
to go
and this is the way it always ends
here it always ends like this
and i will end up here too
but i didn't know you'd end up here so
soon
here's your beer
i'll pour it in the grass for you
i'll put this bar of surf wax
on top of your gravestone
the guitar pick next to it
i read the words
etched in that white granite rock
seth a stone
commander
the u.s navy afghanistan
iraq
september 17 1976
september 30th 2017.
silver star with oak leaf cluster
bronze star medal with valor
faithful warrior
i always tell everyone to carry on
to mourn but not to dwell
but now i'm dwelling myself
and i know i shouldn't
you know i shouldn't
i've thought long and hard about it
and i was going to say goodbye
but i'm not gonna say it
there's no need
you're still with me
you're in the ocean and in the sky
and in the earth beneath my feet
you're still with me
and i'm good with that
here's one more thing you wrote
i fought the enemy as good as i could
i lost myself but in doing so
i found myself
it is a path
you have to work your own one out
it is a struggle
i have listened to the truth
i am humbled and mystified
by this life we live
that's what you said
and i will tell you this my brother
i am humbled and mystified by this life
too
and i am going to keep on living it
i can't stop the sunsets and i can't
bring them back but i can make them
[Music]
count
and that
is what i am going to do
i am going to keep on living
and i am going to make it
count
so
uh
here we are
and speaking
of living life
and trying to make it count
we're doing this gig here
tonight
so
we are live we are
yeah yeah
[Applause]
you